But they put you to the flyer, they said they threw it away.
They picked up your flyer, threw it away,
and then after that, they contacted you because of the ad.
The ad, yeah, exactly like that, yes.
It just comes down to repetition,
like they could have maybe seen the flyer,
you know, took a quick glance to it,
and then it just connected the pattern.
We're like, oh, this is the guy that left the flyer.
Like, let me hit him up.
That's it.
How much was that project?
You may not have been with the 12,000
and we ended up walking in for a long time,
because we're still gonna add a few things afterwards.
Oh, yeah, but for now, it came down to 100,
and then definitely with the change orders
and moving things around, up selling it,
then you'll definitely bring it up.